thank you nate all right when there's
caviar on the menu at my home i know
that it's new year's eve but if you're
looking to enjoy the delicacy while out
on the strip major domo meat and fish
inside the venetian resort has you
covered so let's welcome executive chef
michael rubinstein to tell us more thank
you uh yeah so this dish is uh part of
our special new year's menu uh only
available on new year's eve and you're
only available
so caviar what better to ring in the new
year than with two different types of
caviar both be available uh at majordomo
at the palazzo okay and what better to
have caviar with than with hot fresh
potato chips okay so this is unique
usually i do a little bread square or
something like that a little
pancake right so this is hot fresh
potato chips this dish is actually a
collaboration between
our two restaurants so we have major
domo at the plaza and we also right
across the hallway we have uh moon
palace where they do sliders and hot
chips so
we do two different flavors of chips we
do a savory we just have some fresh
chips here
and i i like the savory with the caviar
but
have you do people do like a sweet with
caviar yeah absolutely absolutely okay
um caviar and banana caviar and some
things work really well yeah uh and then
we have we have honey butter flavor
chips as well
so we'll be offering both come with the
dish so people can kind of decide which
one they like best
so yeah let's make it super simple we
have our fresh chips here we've got some
creme fraiche uh we made this in house
fresh creme fraiche you guys made it
yourselves wow exactly
so what's the vibe while we make this
what's the vibe at majordomo for new
year's eve how's the party you guys want
to throw a party it's a big beautiful
restaurant uh there's gonna be it's
gonna be a good time it's gonna be a lot
of music a lot of
a lot of energy in the room it's a great
we need it's a great place to celebrate
new year's it's also probably like the
closest restaurant
uh in the palazzo to the strip so if
anybody's planning on
walking around yeah which i'm sure
everybody will be it's a great place to
do that and we'll have uh not only this
but a couple of other
really great specials going on that
night okay uh so we like to do a little
bit so we have two cup two kinds of
cabbage both okay uh what are the two
kinds of caviar smoked trout row that's
our orange one here
smoky sweet
mildly salty
okay so we almost have about 30 seconds
left before we before we get to anything
else i really want to educate people
right now you can actually eat caviar
all year round because it's you
certainly there's some health benefits
right let's talk about that so caviar is
high in omega-3s
super good for you good for brain health
good for all kinds of things heart
health
so
we've got our
see i just needed one reason to eat
caviar every day of the year and there
there it is
and here you go
hot chip and caviar
okay can you guys see this i'm dipping
my the hot chip in the caviar this is
brand new for me and i am a caviar
connoisseur i thought
oh what do you think oh this is good
excellent wow major demo for new year's
eve everybody julian i'll